all right I think we might as well get
started it's 11 training with 30 minutes
but it's not a lot of time so I'm gonna
get started my name is Felix I work at
slack as a senior staffer on stacks
runtime team which is responsible for Co
maintaining electron I mostly focus on
outreach and education the actual
engineers are sitting down here but I'm
gonna talk a little bit about what
electron is why it is and will show a
little bit of how you would build your
first teeny-tiny app yeah we're gonna
build a tiny code editor it's not gonna
be anything advanced but just so you get
a feeling for how someone would build
something with electron and before we
get into this talk I usually want to
motivate the whole thing a little bit
because one of the biggest concerns I
have today is that there is this notion
of JavaScript being inherently slow or
Electra maps being inherently slow and I
have this feeling that JavaScript today
works a little bit like CGI in the sense
that it's bad when people notice it but
I'm convinced that most people don't
notice in how many places JavaScript can
actually be found and I've brought just
a few of my favorite examples this one
is the one that surprises people the
most but the user interface and
battlefield one is a typescript and
reactor application the little
ammunition counter that whole thing it's
all react it's actually backed by ma
packs with about a thousand observables
and the thing that I always like to
point out here is that as someone who
comes from native development I've been
beating this we should do web
technologies drum for about 10-15 years
now obviously a JavaScript conference
but there's this like understanding that
JavaScript is supposedly easier and
maybe not as good as native technologies
I can assure you that the people working
at dice do know a thing or two about
native development they're quite good a
building complex native applications but
there's a reason why they chose
typescript and react to build a user
interface and that is that the web
really is one of the best technologies
we have today for building user
interfaces that contain information it's
just really really good at it
right it's that's a very important point
and the other example I have is from a
similar similar point of view it's the
NVIDIA GeForce experience if you have a
Windows device that hasn't
your graphics card you have this
application installed it comes with the
drivers and the nvidia geforce
experience comes with not only web
components but also no js' every single
and video driver contains a version of
nodejs and it's used for communication
between the GPU and applications and
nvidia tools so things like the nvidia
in-game experience we can record things
all of that is handled via nodejs
and this is an interesting use case for
me because we often talk about node.js
as being cross platform and JavaScript
being cross-platform and video doesn't
really necessarily care about all of
that it's just a really convenient way
to write this kind of stuff and again I
love this Nvidia example because the
Nvidia people to have a whole plethora
of coding languages to choose from and
it's not that there's a bunch of people
sitting in a video and going oh be sadly
only know JavaScript if only there was
anything else we could use they've
chosen this tool because it is really
the best one for the application and
then lastly the Adobe Creative Suite
which is sort of and the way they
designed that cross-platform solutions a
little bit like the grandfather of
electron because the Adobe Creative
Suite was one of the first applications
that shipped with the chrome content
module and nodejs embedded so every
single time you open up Photoshop
Lightroom Premiere Pro any of those
creative adobe applications you're
opening up nodejs and chrome it's not
the whole application but they do power
the plug-in experience with those two
tools and the reason they did that is to
allow plugin developers including Adobe
itself to build cross-platform
experience that can hook into the native
experience there was the idea right we
didn't really have a solution for
building semi native code they could
hook into the operating system and also
build some kind of user interface for
plugin developers so they chose those
two technologies and then lastly the
fury Laelius a few latest came all the
electronic occasions there's a few
famous examples that you may have heard
of Visual Studio code is sort of our
poster child slackers the one that I
work on but there's also ones that I
find personally more interesting as an X
Microsoft person the installer for
visual studio itself the big Visual
Studio is written in an electron
application which is
one of my favorite stories but there's
so many other ones right
whatsapp I personally built a little
windows 95 emulator and electron there's
dozens of applications out there and
chances that you're running electron
application on your notebook are pretty
actually pretty high I just want to do
this real quick how many of you are
running either Visual Studio code slack
Microsoft teams discord or Adam on your
device nice cool see that makes us very
happy isn't that exciting so whenever
you give this talk and it's gotten
better over the years but it certainly
at the beginning did I just lose the
display
all right that's got to be difficult
what do we do
any ideas do if any of you people here
yeah that they are cool howdy
we just lost our presentation okay cool
enough that was easy
literally just press one button er thank
you okay
so whenever I give that presentation the
the reaction isn't great and it wasn't
great before we started working this
electron thing before that it was
wouldn't a asked this notion of writing
Windows applications and web
technologies but there's a real reason
why we're doing it right and the primary
reason that I want to point out is that
most of the people working on electron
even the people using electron today
would gladly choose something else on
electron so if you have a bunch of
native developers the slack runtime team
is made up entirely by native developers
who then learned JavaScript we chose
this tool not because we didn't have
anything else available but because we
tried everything else and everything
else is terrible this brilliant no other
way to say that which pains me but
especially if you want to build a
cross-platform application that is
supposed to run on Windows seven and up
with a big one Windows 7 was released
the same year as the iPhone 3 which by
the way I had the headline feature of
copy and paste and sending pictures via
text messages that's how old this
operating system is so if you want to
support that operating system together
with the modern Windows systems and Mac
OS and Linux there really isn't much and
there certainly isn't much that doesn't
require you to build a bunch of native
applications for each platform so with
that being said what is
electron-electron is a combination of
three major components the first one
being the chrome content module this is
in your head basically in an analogue to
chromium right it's the anything chrome
deems necessary to build a browser -
everything that is google-specific
so no Google profiles but everything you
need to turn JavaScript HTML CSS into
pixels and then we have no js' the v8
runtime you all love dearly right and
then we have a very thick layer of c++
around it and this layer of c++
implements a bunch of api's you might
need to build a native application those
are things like interacting with the
native window object or sending native
notifications or interacting with a
touch bar whatever you might need and
there's a pretty thick layer of c++ and
electron comes with that allows you to
do that cross-platform so how do you
actually use all of that right that's
the demo part we're going to do this
little little electron thing and because
Visual Studio code is essentially a
poster child what I want to do is I want
to tell you about Monica editor which
you might already know it's very
possible but Monica editor is a thing
implemented in Microsoft a bunch of
years ago as Visual Studio online which
didn't really work out and eventually
became a part of era websites and it was
sort of this notion that in Azure you
had a little little pen and when you hit
it you could edit your website as your
website itself wasn't the biggest
success but this little text editor was
pretty damn good and at that time
someone made this joke of oh if you put
that in a window and I give it to people
they're gonna use it which was a funny
joke but you know then then they did it
so that's how we have Visual Studio code
today so we're gonna do the same thing
right like this is how many electronic
applications begin they start as a
website or a web application that is
extremely powerful and then eventually
someone goes oh this could be an amazing
desktop application if only could do X
right and X could be whatever you want
because no GS allows you to write in
whatever you want if you want to write C
or C++ or anything else we have a lot of
objective-c and select desktop
applications you can do that you have
native know that ons but that's usually
all begins and makin is a visual studio
coat the most obvious thing that
happened was this would be a great text
editor if only could read and save files
which is one of the basic features of a
text editor which in 2019 you can
actually do with the browser but certain
individuals
code started you couldn't write and if
you think about the editor today it has
a native debugger right all kinds of
features that you can't really do in a
website so let's actually do that and go
through the motion what I have here is
the most simple of the most simple of
index files is an index which is and
we're going to start by turning that
into a note package there we go so now
we have a package Jason and in this
package Jason what we would normally do
if we were to build a node application
is that we defined a start script right
and for most applications
there will be no dot notice all of the
runtime that runs our JavaScript right
so when we execute this application with
an NPM start what happens is that note
reads our index dot js9 it's a console
log and then eventually executes it so
to turn this into an electronic
application the first step we take is
extremely simple
we npm install electron which will
install electron as a dependency it's a
fairly straightforward process we
download the electron for your current
platform and then in the picture Jason
will you place our node with electron
when we execute this application is that
correct writing will start what happens
now is that more or less the same thing
happens when you boot up electron we
start something called the main process
which to you might look and feel a lot
like a normal node process there's one
important difference the first one is
that you can now see electron down here
we are an actual application and the
other one is that the script doesn't
immediately exit but otherwise this is
basically node if you want to require s
you can do that and you can use this any
any given node script will be basically
run here right you have everything else
that you have normally available and
this is our main process once we've
started this main process we also boot
up everything we need for Chrome so
those are typical things like the GPU
process and then eventually we can start
additional
renderer processes which for us are
windows so when you want to build a
desktop application one of the most
important pieces of primitives you have
is the user interface the window that
you're going to start painting things in
and the way electron solves that is that
it should feel very familiar to anyone
who's used to node applications and that
you already know the FS module you know
the Utah module we have one additional
one that is called electron right so you
can can do this in electron itself
contains a bunch of modules the first
one being the app module and the second
one being the browser window module and
those are the ones we're going to use
for a second so the application object
allows us to interact with the
applications lifecycle on your operating
system what I mean by that is when you
start an electron application this main
process never has any user interface
it's always invisible on Windows you
don't even have anything in your in your
taskbar but we also boot up the GPU
process and various services and
eventually those services are going to
be ready and ready for you to start
doing UI stuff so we're gonna say
application on ready to do things now
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
make a window just like so and now when
we start this application we get an
empty window nothing super exciting here
in fact if you open the developer tools
they crash immediately because they do
expect some kind of content which is
currently not present but let's
fundamentally open up a browser window
and we're going to start doing we're
gonna start doing user interfaces here
but one cool thing about electron is
that we can combine the powers of node
with the power of chromium so a
specification I can say web preferences
total integration true and now it's the
next step I'm going to make an HTML file
something small prepared here right it's
a little HTML file that contains some
very bare-bones content
and then my index J is I'm going to load
set file okay so that brings us one step
closer to an actual application in that
we now have a window we have a dock icon
and in the window we have actual content
but the thing that makes this very
quickly very interesting is if i zoom in
here is that we have all of node
available here including native modules
if you want to so if I want to read
anything this works this is here in my
window so that allows you to combine the
powers that you know from the Dom CSS
with everything you know from node right
so if you have a piece of native code
say sequel light or something you can
load that here that actually works and
you can combine those two things
together and what I'm gonna do so I'm
going to install Monaco loader the
moniker editor
these are modules that are normally
consumed with webpack or some other
common J's and port turn into web stuff
kind of tools but I'm gonna go ahead and
add a renderer ojs and because in here I
already explained that we have no
available
speaking about miles Universal
JavaScript I can just do common J's in
my browser that works because it's just
note right I'm just doing no things here
so in here if I do a quick console
console lock hello we run this again to
open up the console you will see my
little hello right there so taking that
one step further let's actually start
building our editor a few things I'm
going to do I'm going to start by
actually including the loader itself and
this is not electron specific this could
be any nodejs code it's just that this
is fairly simple and straightforward
code therefore good for demonstration
and now I'm going to get my Def Con stay
a document.getelementbyid II container
and this is cool
you know how you sometimes need to do
some kind of a Stefan node and then you
install 50,000 modules because
implementing a canvas and raw JavaScript
is kind of difficult we have to fold um
available here all of it whatever you
need so now that we have our div when I
create a little editor and this is
Monaco specific code but what I'm doing
is I'm saying hey dear Monaco editor
please create a new editor in the div
language of on JavaScript and as theme I
want vs dark when we start this is going
to look terrible but I'm gonna do it
anyway just so you see how terrible it
looks looks like this little fin not to
worry though you know like you like a
good chef I've prepared some CSS but
hopefully complicated what I'm doing is
I'm saying no margins on padding's no
overflow make sure the editor itself has
a 100% width and height and then I'm
using I'm giving the container also full
width and height of the viewport which
it's an interesting point for me because
depending on which browser you support
that is a variable you couldn't use on
your CSS right viewport height and width
is not crazy new but if you consider
supporting something as far back as ie8
ie9 because you have an enterprise
communication tool like slack and you
need to support enterprise environments
those values would not be okay right
but since I'm shipping my own browser
engine I don't really have to worry
about that and getting a new browser
engine into an enterprise environment
it's a lot easier than convincing you
know some super secure environment to
install an entirely new browser so we've
done that and we can start this
application again and now we get
something that looks a little bit like
Visual Studio code itself let's move
this over here this over here and if I
wanted to I can now load my actual app
in here you can zoom in yet I didn't we
didn't build the whole zoom thing yet
we can but I don't think it's actually
gonna work oh no it does just the
keywords and yeah there we go
and believe it or not this is pretty
much the bare-bones version of Visual
Studio code right like most of the
things we use in Visual Studio code
every single day and are available in
this teeny tiny application there isn't
really that much more that people did
the first version edit local loading and
saving using the FS module right just
read it in save it out and more or less
that's everything that happened here
which is an interesting point to talk a
little bit about the challenges right I
promise in the abstract that we would
talk a little bit about what makes this
difficult and there's one very common
pitfall that many applications fall into
right after realizing all these powers
so what electron essentially does is
that it takes web developers and gives
them all the powers of node or it takes
no developers and gives them all the
powers of user interfaces sooner or
later someone is going to have the
really clever idea of doing all of that
and then loading something from the
internet right that would be a very
straightforward process would be like
why do we even ship on our HTML we could
just load it from the Internet and that
is probably the biggest challenge
because that is a terrible terrible idea
and that's a terrible idea because again
you have all of node available which has
the same rights as you and it has a
child process and if you want to spawn
things you can do that so the way
electron is used today by modern
applications is one of two ways the
first one is the visual studio code way
where you do actually ship all of your
application code and you trust that code
and you have node code that you trust
right and then the alternative is the
model that slack is currently following
where we do load web content but we
don't really trust that web content we
say ok this web content might have a
right um - more than the actual than in
a browser but we controlled very neatly
and very very narrowly what kind of
features are available there and the way
that is usually managed is that the
renderer process in the main process can
communicate via something called the
inter process communication module which
is a little advanced and sometimes new
Forno developers and also
developers because most of us aren't
actually used to multi-process coding
let alone multi-thread coding but
fundamentally the idea here is that you
sort of choose your you choose your
poison I do either don't trust while
you're loading and then you need to
control what kind of things that
application can do or you ship
everything with your application and
that is probably the biggest challenge
and now that we've pulled this
application the next typical step for
people would be that you go ahead and
try to turn that into an actual binary
right and there's various solutions
available for that one of the things
that is great about electron is that
tons of applications depend on it
because tons of applications depend on
it the ecosystem is extremely rich to
date there is more than 1500 modules
available at npm that do something
electron specific and usually that thing
is to an electron into a certain
application package right if you want to
ship your electrode application to the
snap craft store that is available if
you want to notarize it with Mac OS that
is available and one of the one of the
tools that does it extremely well is
electron Forge as built by Sam or
sitting right there so if you don't like
it please annoy him immediately but what
electron Forge does is that it allows
you to take your application and
immediately turn that into a binary
without having to worry about anything
too much it's it's very straightforward
and very quick so if we you know if you
want to see that in action one of the
applications I would recommend to look
at is electrons own little application
called fiddle which also lets you play
with electron itself fiddle is sort of
the thing that we just built except that
we kept going fill this a little code
editor that allows you to build little
teeny tiny electron experiments and play
with them and you can check out various
tools in there so if you want to see
something like the desktop capturer
which is a tool that lets you just
install catallena shouldn't have done
that
there we go yes fine okay nothing is
allowed anymore gotta ask for everything
so anyway as I was saying if you want to
see something like the desktop capture
on action you can run this little
application and the desert capture is
broken which we will debug later but
it's it's a little application that's
not only open-source
it's also using electron forge so you
can sort of see how we turn this
application into actual binaries we do
all of that in CI building a complete
new version of this doesn't really
require for me anything else and a
little iPad and it's also a little
tighter and neater than Visual Studio
code itself which is also open source
but might be a bit of a mouthful if you
start there right because obviously that
application has been in the works for a
while all right we have about five
minutes for Q&A if anyone has any
questions while we do that I'm gonna
leave this open if any of you want to
get started with it and haven't yet
recommend fiddle recommend electron j/s
fiddle also allows you to export your
little experiments as a forge project so
you can build something tiny just
exported as a desktop app send it to
your parents right which is honestly one
of the big benefits of any of you write
NPM modules you can send you a little
NPM modules to Grandma and she can run
it which might be more difficult than
NPM install instructions all right if
there are no questions you can find me
on Twitter you can find electron on
Twitter you can also find many of us
here today so if any of any questions
that you don't to ask here just find us
later things you all for coming by
[Applause]